avec les sénateurs avec les sénateurs
les républicains je crois qu'aujourd'hui
nous ne sommes pas
une mission on fabrique la loi on
contrôle le gouvernement nous portons la
réalité territoriale de ce pays qui a eu
beaucoup de mal à se faire entendre
depuis plusieurs années mais dans ces
collectivités territoriales vivent des
hommes et des femmes
ceux qui sont les hommes et les femmes
des territoires qu'ils soient ruraux
urbains où qu'ils soient aussi des
français qui vivent en dehors de la
france et c'est ça la représentation des
territoires des territoires dont nous
souhaitons qu'ils puissent contribuer à
une france vivante une france active par
ces territoires
et c'est cela le rôle du sénat
tout simplement parce que le maire
incarne l'élu de proximité et c'est dans
la proximité que on peut incarner la
confiance tout ce qui est éloigné
inspire souvent la défiance les maires
sont apportés d'engueulades et on le dit
souvent les mères sont en première ligne
ce sont les fantassins de la république
c'est eux qui panse les plaies c'est eux
qui est aussi porte des projets et je
pense que cette proximité qu'ils ont
avec leurs administrés avec leurs
habitants leur assure une confiance et
cette confiance là de sondage en sondage
les français l'ont toujours réaffirmée
les maires sont les visages de la
république et c'est vrai que parfois la
république que l'état n'a pas été
attentive au maire à ce qu'ils vivent
dans la proximité dans la gestion de
leur collectivité depuis un certain
nombre d'années entre accroissement
normatif j'allais dire avalanche
normative baisses de dotations
responsabilités accrues ces mères
aujourd'hui c'est eux qui tiennent la
république dans les difficultés que
traverse notre pays depuis l'automne
2010 8
c'est eux qui incarne le ciment de la
république est donc aujourd'hui ils sont
35 mille fois des petites républiques
dans la grande
le sénat s'est attaqué à cette abondance
normative depuis longtemps grâce
notamment avec la délégation aux
collectivités à la fois par exemple sur
les sur transposition européenne parce
que on empile énormément de contraintes
et on a essayé aussi de promouvoir une
norme à chaque fois qu'une norme est
implanté dans notre édifice législatif
ou réglementaire deux normes au moins
devraient en sortir
un acte iii c'est un autre état d'esprit
de la décentralisation nous avons sans
doute un peu perdu ce qui est à
l'origine de la décentralisation c'est
une confiance pour les élus pour les
élus du territoire et cette confiance
nous l'avons perdue avec les normes avec
un contrôle tatillon avec un état qui au
lieu d'être un partenaire est devenue
quelque part une forme de régulateur
supérieur et qui aujourd'hui la compagne
plus les collectivités territoriales
confiance adaptation d'un certain nombre
de réponses en fonction des territoires
et puis un état qui accompagne et non
pas un état qui est simplement le juge
c'est notre groupe qui a fait un certain
nombre de propositions dans le cadre
aussi de la délégation des collectivités
territoriales une trentaine de
propositions qui touchent l'ensemble du
statut d'élu jusque par exemple à la
formation c'est aussi ici au sénat qu'on
a réglé juste avant noël dans la loi de
finances une injustice fiscale
flagrantes notamment pour les communes
de moins de 3500 habitants
il faut là aussi sans doute remettre
l'ouvragé sur le métier
mais au jour d'aujourd'hui je pense par
exemple qu'on ne doit pas assimiler ce
qui est de l'ordre de l'indemnité qui
est une compensation pour des frais que
les maires seront à une rémunération à
un revenu donc c'est à chaque fois la
vie concrète des mères dans leur commune
pour leur activité que on doit essayer
d'assouplir parce que cela nous sentons
bien qu'on ne peut pas avoir un nouvel
acte de la décentralisation
on ne peut pas s'appuyer sur la commune
qui est le socle de la république
si quelque part on ne reconnaît pas le
rôle et la place du maire si on lui
accorde pas une forme de sécurité
juridique
si on lui accorde pas non plus à ce mr
une reconnaissance pour sa réinsertion
professionnelle par exemple si on lui
reconnaît pas des droits sociaux je
crois que cette reconnaissance là elle
est indispensable pour avoir la gestion
la plus apaisé la plus sereine avec un
conseil municipal de la commune de
l'intercommunalité